um my name is john drewd
i'm the ceo of ofra mathcore and
we develop system modeler as well as
provide consulting solutions related to
just the modeler but also other wolfram
technologies and today
i'm going to talk about new
stuff in system modular and related
[Music]
related projects and
i think before actually
starting the presentation i want to show
a short part of the video few
a few a few
weeks ago a colleague of mine
had seen this video about the tennis
racket effect
i don't know if you heard about it but
it's
sort of explained in this video in 2017
and after rescuing the space station
janabekov unpacked supplies sent up from
earth
which were locked down with a wingnut
and as the wingnut spun off the bolt
he noticed something strange the wingnut
maintained its orientation for a short
time
and then it flipped 180 degrees and as
he kept watching
it flipped back a few seconds later and
it continued flipping back
and forth at regular intervals this
motion wasn't caused by forces or
torques applied to the wingnut
there were none and yet it kept flipping
it was a strange and counter-intuitive
phenomenon
one that the russians kept secret for 10
years
okay um you might ask yourself what that
has to do with system over
i will get back to that
later on but in general i would say that
what it has to do with this model that
modeling is a lot about
trying to investigate things that are
sort of hard
to understand sometimes and getting new
insights
so i'll get back to that
for bandwidth reasons i think i will
shut down my
my video for now and
perhaps get it back on later
okay
so first of all um in march
this year together with uh
with the release of mathematica at well
one we also
release system model 12-1 and one thing
that
happened there that is is perhaps not
super important but that you might have
noticed
is that we used to type system over this
way
but instead we started to
add a dash so we're not camel casing at
the moment
uh or any longer uh instead we have two
separate words
and at the moment you will see different
versions of it
but gradually it will be switching to
that system
modeler 12-1 in 12-1
the key features were
the new synchronous library that i hope
some of you have
been able uh had an opportunity to use
uh it was improved error reporting that
sort of included when you get the
error message for some coding you you
the some coding mistake you actually get
links that takes you to the right line
of code and so on
and simplified creation of configurable
models so models
where you can easily have different
configurations with
for instance changing a specific
component
according to a ready made list
even though this was released this year
i will not cover that
today we i covered most of those topics
in last year's conference so i can
recommend you to listen into that one if
you if you want to
hear that but also of course going to
the website where we are covering
the things which you can see basically
it will look like this where you have
the different parts and you can click to
different resources in order to see
whether it's videos or examples that
illustrates
these different features that we added
okay instead uh
i would like to go to something that is
more of sort of
systematic related projects it's not the
product itself but things that
that make the use of the product product
easier
a couple of like a month ago or
something like that
three weeks ago perhaps we started study
groups in system modeling
so you might have heard about this
concept of study groups that voltron has
added during the year if you if you saw
stephen's stephen's keynote he mentioned
these
and in the system modeling
study group there was eight
different uh sections
one each day of the
the course all of them you can see
roughly an hour
and these were interactive of course
live just as sort of
at the moment but you can still go and
see these
online and and to learn more how to use
system modeler so here you go to the
side and you can see
different courses that are available and
we should here is we have the system
modeling
section so then you can go in and if you
want to learn sort of the basics of
system already you can click to this one
and and follow that one if you want to
learn more about how to use it in
chemistry
you can click on this one and so on and
the first parts are
sort of something you can basically just
listening to
get an idea of how to use the product
while the later ones
are more interactive and and where you
uh are expected to install this have the
software installed and so on so you get
exercises to
to follow along and i guess we will
rerun this also if you want to have a
more interactive version where you can
actually
have some questions and answers
another one of these things that i won't
cover too much because we have a
specific talk on that
uh is the virtual labs which we have
started to to release
these are specifically targeted towards
education in high school and college but
i'll get back to that
then
[Music]
a happy surprise of good timing was that
last week
a new book consistent modeler was
released it's written by
a professor from
saint petersburg in russia and from
malaysia so
you can buy this book at springer and if
i click here
get to that link i can post the links
for you later on and you
by the way you can also downl
okay so here you can see it and already
now it's
835 downloads i can see uh of the book
so that's good but there's also of
course a physical
copy of it that you can buy and we hope
that this will help your
self as well as colleagues to get
started in system with system modeler
okay um since the mother 12 2
is getting released the just as for
mathematica
the code freeze for functions the new
new functionality was
a few days ago so right now it's in the
middle of
sort of stabilizing the product and
getting things to to run
smoothly so it's a perfect timing to
have
to have a live demos of course
and i in general i would say that
that 12-2 is a lot about getting
better workflows and and making it
easier to
to develop your models and document your
models in a sense and i have selected
three as well as sort of keeping the
progression of being able to model more
and more
things i have chosen three things
to focus on here today it's
annotational plots it's uh
that we are finally and this has been
asked for a lot adding
uh the fluid library an experimental
version of it
and then we have something that says
create system
models from regions and i think i will
take these in
in a slightly different order than i
here let's start with the regions
and that will take us back to the tennis
racket i think
so something we made possible now i will
start here with
with importing a cad shape so it's a
wing nut
remember that there was a wing not in
the example we saw
so what i will do i have downloaded a
wingnut from
from a resource of free
free cad drawings
and then i will import this as a
boundary mesh region
so now i have my wing nut here in
mathematica and of course it's just a
can shape and
doesn't really do much in itself rather
other than perhaps looking good i guess
but what i can do now is actually i can
take this shape or any
any or other regions i can create within
mathematica i could use the
the mathematica primitives for of course
to create
a graphics also or a region once i have
the region what i can do
is i can create a system model from this
so look here what i'm doing here i'm
creating a system outlet
model called wingnut within the package
new in system modeler
and i'm using this wingnut component
that i created here so
this will not here is what i'm using to
create the model
then i have i'm scaling it because
whoever draw this
wingnut drew made the
biggest wing nut ever is about
if i remember correctly like 25 meters
in diameter
so it's a rather big nut so i'm making
it
slightly smaller still huge but smaller
so that's why we have this option here
otherwise we could
skip the parameter values if if the wing
nut was
sort of more realistic size
so then with this what happened here is
if i go over to system
i should be able to see it here now wing
nut here and you see it's updated
in bold it's because we added that as a
model
and this actually doesn't only add sort
of the graphics it adds a bit more and
we'll get back to that
next thing i'll do is i'll use this
newly created component
and create an example with it and
so using connect system model components
i'll take the take this wingnut and the
world object
for those of you that are familiar with
the 3d multibody
library of system modeler you sort of
know what this is for others this is
basically
a component that defines uh things like
gravity
and and coordinate system and so on so
you know where in the world you are and
how
sort of it's it's
working uh and we can see what i do here
is i i
i'll define the gravity to zero because
up in space
where where this example we saw is going
on
there's basically no gravity so let's
set it to zero
and then i'll also initiate the
wing nut with the initial velocity so we
will sort of
be traveling at this velocity here 0.1
meters per second
and it will be rotating around the same
axis
with 10 radians per second so i do shift
enter
and now i have created a model
using this so i can look at that
i don't know how to pronounce it and
it's
the cosmonaut that sort of saw this
happening in space
and this is the simple model we have
nice okay so now
without having to do anything more we
actually have set up
a complete system that we can simulate
and see how it works
so i run system modeler with the
animation
option here to open the animation window
this simulates the model first and then
opens the animation
well and before simulating it as those
that you that
you has used system one knows what it
does is sort of compile
and so on so let me do this
okay now my windows bar came up here can
i
let's put it on repeat and let's go and
see what happens so
i'm starting trap there is flips
so just based on
the shape and calculating so
automatically we're now
calculating the the
moment of inertias and so on needed in
order to
to simulate this and
just by starting it on the constant
speed and the constant rotation we can
see exactly
the thing that happened in the video
it's happening here too
i don't know about you guys but i have
been looking at this many times and it's
sort of
it's hard to understand and once you
start looking at
ex exactly how sort of the
the wing nut start to flip a bit you can
start to understand why it actually
flips
but the most amazing thing is how it
actually comes back into balance and
these are the kind of things that you
sort of want to
simulate and start to analyze in order
to understand what's going on
okay
so uh next yeah
is let's close this down
is the fluid library i'm going to
reverse here
and i will run a drum boiler example
drum boilers are typically used in when
you are
like in in power plants for instance uh
so you
from uh using a
drum here or the actual drum boiler
you have liquid and
water in two phases liquid and vapor
so liquid is coming in here and then
vapor is leaving and that is the way we
sort of using
later on for producing electricity
and but anyways what
the fluid library enables is these
options in order to sort of
go from one phase to another uh using
the media
medium library that we had media library
that we had before
uh it it has a whole bunch of components
for these purposes so we can basically
what we have to do as is an experimental
version
is you have and i've already done that
but you have to sort of right click on
modality
version and then you choose the with
fluid library experimental down here
and then what you will get is here fluid
library
and you can see that it has different
things like about
sources and so on okay
and here we have an example
that i have the example i talked about
we have the diagram here and let's
just simulate that for to see that it
actually
works and
and it will not be a course of course in
in in in
the actual half hour drama boiler
works uh but if you're interested in
that you can of course
download the model later and try to
understand it okay so this i
have some bug here in the
in the functionality that scales a bit
bad here i have now
predefined a model plot
and what you can see now uh on my screen
there's a bug that makes these sort of
uh titles a bit big but this is things
that are interesting that we're
underpossible to to sort of
put titles more easily but also captions
and these captions can be actually a bit
more interactive so let's see
or update it more
easily so if i go in here this plot
properties
this comes now to annotating your your
figure so let's say here that you would
like to
add some kind of reference to
a variable that is in the model so you
would say um
always i have to learn the variable
and then you can link to variable here
so you can find any
variable here i start to type something
for instance
p and it's here
okay sorry subplot
variable air link target
variable name
and i can give it some some things like
pressure
i can also i i i can also add
a finally three steps
and reference between plots and so on
okay and now we can see the variable
pressure has the final
value 89 bars
and getting soon running out of time
i think that's good timing and we can
see here
now that i can also go to find it in
model center
so i click ps it selects it's here it
selects is here
so that way you can easily sort of find
your your uh
the things that you are uh linking to
nice so these are uh three of the things
i wanted to
showcase for system all 12.2 basically
making it easier to
to document your models by annotations
the new fluid
experimental fluid library and system
modeling from regions
so i think it's pretty cool
before leaving for a short q a and
i just wanted to mention that there are
yes coming up directly after this one uh
there's a presentation
where i get nike will uh explain how
prof professor mattijo fasano from
italy could increase his student
capacity for 30 to 300 in an instant
and that was sort of something that he
that happened when the lockdown for
kovind 19 came
in in italy and he's thought he
would have no possibility of doing his
classes in the way he wanted
instead of sort of shutting them down he
could scale it up to 300. and we'll
shoot and
ankit will cover that then
after that leonardo laguna will
show you how system model sounds uh
and i bet it sounds really good
and af
consultant business consultant will show
a new business simulation library that
is coming up
with system modeler uh 12 2 or just
after 12.2
and how this sort of takes system
dynamics to a new level
something that is not necessarily a
system model related but as i'm sort of
organizing it this together with jeremy
davis i
like to invite you guys to come to
france tomorrow
and visit that with us
so if you look at the agenda you will
find a
virtual gym hour and there you can read
a bit more
about the if you want to sort of
the chances of visiting france tomorrow
or
strolling around your neighborhood to
to find different things
finally on friday i did some
kobe 19 modeling early this year and i'm
sort of trying to give the verdict
of of that simulation that i did in
april was i even close
or did i fail completely
okay um q a i will have a short q a here
but
[Music]
i would like to invite you for more
questions later on as
we have a bunch of presentations today
we have
decided that our booth session at
noon today will have an extended q a
from today's system other presentations
so if you go drop in there and how
you you are welcome with questions for
this presentation as well as
other presentations today um and of
course if you have other questions
then those you're welcome with those two
then on thursday
we sort of focus on on consulting
services so if you have questions
regarding consulting you will come there
yet again if you have other questions
you're also welcome but we try sort of
so if several people have the same sort
of interest
it might be a good opportunity to join
in and finally on friday
tell us which features you want in next
version of system modeler so
with that i'll just click on this one
so you see where that sort of
that was yeah let's see yeah so here you
see the booth
and the guys that will be present there
it's myself leonardo laguna ruiz jorge
and ankit nike
good um that was my presentation i will
see if i can
find some if you have any questions
i will stay here for just one minute or
so
and then we'll uh
after that we'll leave
we i'll leave for ankit's presentation
that is starting
in a few seconds so let's see if i find
the right window here with
that was not okay
for some reason i'm not finding the
right chat here
and got lost but thank you very much and
take care